it's a pleasure to have gurushan Kaur
and we'll be talking about uh
fluctuations on dense random graph
models
thank you and I would like to start by
thanking all the organizers and also to
invite me here this is a very wonderful
place and a lot of interesting talks
that I'm getting to attend
so this is a work on higher order
fluctuations this is a joint work with
Adrian rolin and he talked about this uh
in his talk yesterday
so I'll begin by uh defining what the
subgraph density mean and just going
over the just to fix the notations I'm
explaining this again
so consider as dense graph G on endnotes
then for a finite simple graph F on K
nodes
the sub graph density this density of f
in this graph G is nothing but the
number of injective homomorphisms of F
into G divided by the total
possibilities here so here we want this
scaling is basically to make sure that
the sub graph density t f of G is always
between 0 and 1.
and if you have a graph on then which is
a symmetric measurable function from
this unit Square to zero one
then you construct a graph by first
selecting these node features uniformly
at random from 0 1 and then connect node
I and node J with probability Kappa so
we call the cup we will use the notation
Kappa for our graph one as Adrian also
use in a stock
um you'll see why because we are using W
for something else
so a GN is a graph where you have n
nodes and node features are selected
uniformly at random from zero one and
then you connect I and J with
probability cup of uij
then similar to the subgraph density we
Define for a given graph GN for a graph
on
um when you construct a graph GN you
have the sub expected subcraft density
of f in GN is nothing but this k-fold
integral of the product terms which is
also uh so we call this TF of Kappa
for instance for H density this is a
integral that of Kappa or XY says that
one node is connected with with feature
X is connected to another node deep
feature Y and similarly for triangles we
have X connected to y y with z and Z can
expect to X here
now the dense graph conversions Theory
by lower sensegrity says that if you
have a sequence of dense graphs g n
so here GN is a graph on N nodes or an
increasing sequence of dense graphs then
you call this a conversion sequence if
the sub graph density for every finite
graph F converges
to something
if if all these sequences uh have limit
then you say that the sequence of next
graphs converge
and what what we have uh like the and
the limiting quantity limiting object
can be characterized by a graph on which
is a functioning from unit Square to
zero one
so that all the limiting quantities can
be determined by this graph one
so
and conversely if you have a graph on so
that was one way that you have a
sequence of graphs that converges and
there is a limiting object which you
call a graph on and conversely if you
have a graph one there you can construct
a sequence of graphs that I just did in
my previous slide uh
that you chooses so node labels and
connect them accordingly according to
Kappa
then that sequence converges so for
every graph on copper there exists such
a sequence
and that converges to the quantity that
we defined for Kappa TF of copper
mutually
right now let's consider this uh
favorite example for everyone here which
is the addition random graph you have a
Kappa to be a constant graph on P
and in that case the sequence of dense
graphs converges to a constant graph on
P
with the expected density of any graph F
to be equal to the P to the power the
number of edges we have in that sub
graph f
now as agent mentioned in this talk
yesterday that this is only a first
order limit here you only know about the
convergence and and the next obvious
question that one would like to ask is
if there is a central limit Theory here
now because the first order limit theory
is given in terms of the subgraph
densities
one would expect that the fluctuations
are also can fluctuations can also be
expressed through these update densities
so so you basically want this uh CLT
results for your subdraft densities
but this is the bottleneck here there is
some challenge here so if you look at
this uh okay so this this was a six
point in Adrian stock yesterday as well
if you have a secret erosionic graph
then all the fluctuations
are dominated by the fluctuations in the
S densities
they are all governed by The Edge
densities in your
hydrogeny type graphs or a constant
graph one
now it becomes even more challenging
when you have a general graph on
so if in case of additional graphs these
node levels were really not important
you were just constructing edges
independently it was like tossing a coin
without worrying about the node
um labels or features
but for a general graph on this is even
uh more difficult because all you have
is that the fluctuations are all
dominated by something which depends
only on the Node levels
unlike this uh edoshini case where
everything was determined by The Edge
densities
so if we just work with the sub graph
density then every time you just come
here and you get stuck you don't get
anything much more here
so you definitely need something more
so we go back and look at this work of
Anson and noviki which uh defines the
generalized use statistics and their
application for random graphs
so it is to define the generalized use
statistics let's say you have a function
f from
arcade plus RK choose two to R so our K
choose to is is all possible in case
used to combinations for your indexes so
you have this pairwise dependence also
in in the uh variables here
another various it's arguments
then the generalized use statistics uh
so without this cage used to or
so without this case used to or the Y uh
arguments here this is just a used
classical use statistics
we call it General Science generalized
if you also include uh with this
individual nodes or the labels you also
have this pairwise interaction terms
included in your function
and how they are useful for uh
random graphs is
um from the option of our construction
let's say you have U1 U2 u n be the nid
vertex labels and y i j is be the edge
indicators
now
it you can Define the subgraph indicator
in the following way so we can we can
Define this function f which depends on
this K Indica K vertice labels I 1 to ik
and this Edge indicators such that so so
act actually doesn't just depends on
this vertex indicators uh vertex labels
it's just a product of this Edge
indicators whenever your vertex V and W
are connected in F
so this gives you an indicator this is
one if you have a copy of f on this set
of nodes i1 to ik and it's a zero
otherwise
so what this generalized use statistics
if you uh Define this for this function
f this gives you
um
this is something like a cop number of
copies but it's a bit different from the
way we Define the homomorphism our
subgraph density but it's more or less
the same so
so that the only difference is that we
are looking at the K triples uh with no
repetitions but here it's a bit
different and this scaling is a bit
different but in a sense this is how you
use uh this generalized U statistics for
uh random graphs
now what's the advantage of U statistics
so even when we didn't have a
generalized new statistics without this
interaction variables the U statistics
of when you have this function you can
go back and
so without even without this interaction
terms this new statistics has a very
nice decomposition called the hafting
decomposition now what Jansen and noviki
show that the generalized use statistics
also has a very nice decomposition
but what they have used is that they
want this yijs to be their independent
variables
which may not be the case for our for a
general platform
because because there is a no dependence
for each interaction i j and I K there
is a common vertex level UI sitting
which makes y i j and y i k dependent
they are not independent anymore
but nonetheless uh We've so this is one
of our main um uh uh contribution or is
the idea is more or less coming from the
answer and noviki's work
that the subgraph densities have a
decomposition of the following form
so here uh this is a function this is
some so this is a quantity not uh which
where this node uh
node uh sorry this uh node indicators or
labels view depend only through a uh
sorry H Union a and these are the edge
indicators which find only through h
so so you are summing over all possible
subsets of
uh or some of your all possible sub
graphs of f
and all possible subsets of the node
Center
I'll give an example it might really be
clear more
such that this
terms that you have here they are
orthogonal other pairwise autumni
so what do we mean by Paris orthogonal
here is that whenever you take two
different
copies of H in the sense that they are
not isomorphic
or if you have this node subset a so
that they are not an they are not
equaling the cardinality the number of
nodes are not the same when the
covariance between the two terms that
you have H A or H minor a prime is zero
I have a question on this so you could
have instead choosing instead of
choosing Edge indicators you could have
chosen yij to be uniform in zero one and
then Define your function by saying that
W of x i x j is small or equal y i j and
then you would get the independent Vice
so would that be a way to prove this
yeah that that wouldn't be a problem you
can Define why I just started to because
then you have the independence you need
in the yards yeah
so how come people don't do that no no
so this this can so I'm not saying that
we are doing this for only for the
dependence case uh or we are
generalizing this that's not what we are
doing
so this is this is basically what Jansen
and novike have done uh this is uh the
the idea is we are taken we are taking
this idea from there yeah you're right
that you can Define this Edge indicator
so that they become independent
so um so we have this decom okay so
going back here so we are decomposing uh
the subtract densities into this
pairwise orthogonal terms here r r h k
such that whenever either the two copies
H and H Prime are not isomorphic or if
the number of nodes you have in the set
a they are not exactly the same then the
covariance is zero
now in fact what we so we do this exact
computation and say that this R of H A
are exactly of this form
where this um there's a dependence on H
only through the centered subgraph term
so we call this quantity centered sub
graph so this was without the sentence
so your your call your subtracting the
conditional expectation here
and we call this a centered sub graph
round I'll uh just come to that term
here
uh this is some uh this depends on what
uh Edge you have and what a and what F
you're working with I'll give an example
and it might be it it's a bit tedious to
compute for a given F watch I would be
but uh it so this is some I'll come to
that maybe the example will clear it but
you can find such a decomposition that's
what
your sorry depends on all the u i J's
from J1 to L yes because now it says UI
ah no uh what does it do yeah so so it
depends it depends uh this is only a
function depending on uh UI yes
okay yes thank you
yes so this I is a vector i1 to Il so it
depends shy function depends on all of
these uh this H Union a all this uh
indices you have
and there is a scaling of 1 by square
root n choose l so it's like n to the L
by 2 here
so
so what this decomposition is basically
telling you is that when you when we are
looking at the CLT or this we want to
look at the fluctuations here the
leading order terms or the these are the
terms that are governing your
fluctuations
and once there is a once you see a
leading term then the other terms do not
matter
so that's what was happening for
edoshini and the general graph funds
okay
any any other questions before I move
forward
so it is going back so this is um this
this is our main statistics which we
call the centered sub graph indicators
we say that looking at this uh sub graph
densities through this sub graph
indicators
it's basically nothing is basically uh
the center subgraphs that are playing
the major role here
and this TF this was this so if if we
can show the normal approximation or
some fluctuation results for these
quantities that we have in the sum ends
here then then you will get what happens
for the subgroup densities
and this is our main result here now
uh I'll come to the example a bit later
I'll just State the result first
um so our result says is that is that if
we take any D different graphs f 1 to f
t so so our so what we are trying to do
now is prove Central limit theorem for
these quantities
for this uh
so quantities which are of this type
where you have the centered sub graph
set indicators and they are weighted by
this node labels and scaled
appropriately
so we want to prove uh CLT for such such
things which is exactly this so but what
we have here is a joint CLT for for any
given graph 512 ft which I've connected
uh okay so connected uh we are only
looking at Connected because otherwise
uh the density can be written as a
product of connected component so it's
enough to look at the connected graphs
here
so if you have fnfd of on nodes K1 to KD
then for any asset graph FS here if the
size is only equal to 1 you basically
don't have any Edge so there's no
centered sub graph indicator in hand you
only have this functions depending on
uis so just to make sure that the
limiting normal distribution has mean
zero is a subtract is expected mean of
this quantity and otherwise they are so
these quantities are always mean zero so
that means
whenever the size is at least two you
have at least one Edge in the graph so
you get this
then you combine these the uh
quantities W1 to w d
and what we are saying is that this
variance Matrix W uh so there's a normal
approximation for this Vector W and
let's denote the sigma to be the
variance of uh this is W Matrix and this
is where we use W instead of using it
for the graph on uh which we call Copper
so as as we mentioned last in in the
decomposition that this these two terms
that these uh these terms are
uncorrelated so whenever this uh
functions whenever they are not
isomorphic copies or whenever they are
not exactly this two Singleton nodes
so you see other otherwise you might see
up some positive
oh sorry uh these are this is non-zero
only in this case other in every other
case this Koreans terms are zero and
that's because what Adrian also
mentioned that when you have two
function two sub graphs which are not
isomorphic then there is at least one
free Edge
for which you get the ex
coverings part 0.
so with that uh with this one what we
want to now show is that the uh CLT for
this Vector W two normal standard normal
uh not standard normal normal zero with
this variance Matrix
so what we show is that this indeed
converges uh it has a normal
approximation in the sense that when you
take the Supreme so here we are writing
it in this terms because we are using
Steins method so when you take the
supremum over this difference over a
smooth enough functions so here p is the
maximum you can think of this as a
maximum
um
subgraph size that we have in the
collection of our sub graphs F into f t
then this is bounded above by uh 1 by
square root of n this is of 1 by square
root n uh so this is only on this class
of functions which are P plus 2 times
differentiable
yeah smooth enough functions
and we want if you are looking at the
convex at distance between the
distribution of w and z then this is of
order into the minus 1 by P plus 2.
so I guess in the context of I guess
password stock where there was
degeneracy so would this limit have be
these sort of not full rank normal
distribution or something is that what
happens
now so uh the for us these are centered
subgraph indicators for
so these are these are the terms in your
expansion each of them have normally
approximation
okay thanks yeah I'll come to the I'll
relate to what password talked about and
with an example here Adrian also talked
about that example
okay any other questions before I uh
so uh there are two proof in main proof
ingredients here as I uh explained uh
like so one is uh the composition for
this analyze use statistics
which says that they are the terms are
dependent but uncorrelated
and the the next uh main ingredient is
the science method how do you get the
approximation uh for this for such uh
sums where you don't have the IID or the
uh some but so they are dependent but on
correlated
so going back to the Earth so I'll I'll
talk about these two things a little
more and tell you how this to give you
the flavor how we arrive at this
decomposition
so let's say you so this was our sub
graph indicator right so whenever I is
connected to J in F then uh this
indicator tells you that there is a
graph present on the setup and given set
of endnotes or not
then you can write uh this as a there's
a decom very very this is very simple
decomposition
that you take all possible sub graphs of
H which are which do not contain not
starting with the isolated vertex here
it must at least have one edge here
so it can be empty but should not have
an isolated node so for example so and
and it is of this form I'll come to give
an example and then come back to this so
let's say you have just an edge
this is very simple you can just add and
subtract the it's conditional mean
and
so this is where you have H to be the
empty set
and
yeah so here you have H to be empty and
H here has just one Edge
now when you have two stars
so that I is connected to J and I is
also connected to K then also you can
give this exact so this this is an exact
equality you can just uh keep adding and
subtracting few terms and arrive at this
decomposition where this one is a full
graph uh this two star graph this one
where you have the H is just the ith and
this here your i j is just H and this is
the overall condition mean
so this is what this terms so now you
can prove this by induction so this is a
simple Lemma here that you condition on
this Edge take the center Supra similar
to here similar to what we are getting
these terms here right and on the
remaining graph you take the conditional
expectation so H complement with respect
to F here I mean h complement for not
for uh so whatever edges you have not
covered in h a n f
only for those you are taking this
condition
any any questions um
so now let's Okay so maybe before that
um so so this part is simple
uh for in the decomposition
and now the tricky part uh is or the
tedious part is to approximate these
quantities this product terms
by those individual uis
so we are we are the next step is to
give an orthogonal decomposition for
these product terms
so that you get those Phi of h a shy of
h a and just the uis
okay
so here they are not yet there's no
orthogonal decomposition here
for example the uh stochastic block
model uh where you have uh Alpha so the
gamma is this threshold on the two
communities let's say uh then Alpha is a
probability that two committees are
connected with within themselves uh the
First Community I mean maybe just draw
this it's easier to
foreign
if you look at the edge density now
if I go back and look at the edge
density here
so I only have two terms but I also want
this one to I want to decompose this one
as well further so what what we get here
is that uh the all these terms
by by getting the alternative completion
so here the Kappa bar is just the
overall expectation
and then this W is the
indicator terms that UI is less than
equal to gamma so this is specifically
for the uh stochastic block model and
here this the first term is a part of 1
by square root n the second term is of r
1 by n this this these two both these
two terms are up order one by m and the
third term is our product into the three
half
so then this one uh so this graph has no
no Edge or no no this is just overall
mean this one consists of one node level
and here this is an edge graph so it's
like an uh you are decomposing this sub
graph density into increasing sequence
of sub graphs of the ish oh yeah
and what uh talked about this is
whenever you are this Row one so Row one
is you can you have exact expression
Point O one for this particular example
whenever Row one is equal to 0
then this dot this is not a dominating
term
or when Row 1 is non-zero then this is
the dominating term
so you have the gaussian limit here but
because we know that w
so I now can re-ask the question I asked
and pass first talk sort of because you
have this nice formula
he never had the case where O2 is zero
I'm sorry so what if row two were zero
well
but remaining this we
should also converges to normal when you
when you scale it appropriately so this
this one is normal so oh I see so for
example two is zero or not you always
have a one over enter
yeah so this this one if this one
survives
yeah then you always have this one by n
term
but there's no chi-square component if
root is zero
and and for instance uh this last term
that you have here n to the three half
this is 0 for a constant graphing couple
yes
now so this was about the the
composition now little bit about this
times method I'll talk about not not
going too much into details
so what we do is uh any other question
about the decomposition before I start
about the Stein method
that might be confusing at the beginning
can you go back all the way to the r
values there might be some typo that
might have made things a bit confusing
one
um
yes the we're not deriving a normal
approximation for the R's the R's is
just a nothogonal decomposition
they are uncorrelated but the R's
themselves need not they can but need
not be normal maybe that's that's uh
yeah that's maybe a typo there that yeah
so yeah right sorry so the r's are just
the R's themselves are further
decomposed the quantities that are
normal they can be squares or sums of
quantities that themselves are normal I
mean that's just to clarify them right
right so these are your art terms but
you are basically giving a normal
approximation for these statistics
instead of this not not for this whole
term but just uh right
thing
so uh okay yeah
any other comment question
so we're going so how do we prove that
after you have a decomposition how do
you prove uh how do you get the rate of
convergence here
so we use the science method where the
for the denominational uh distribution
the normal distribution the science
identity say that a random a normal Z
which has a normal distribution with
mean Vector zero and various Matrix
diagonal identity
Lindsay has a normal distribution if and
only if the following expression holds
this is just a generalization of science
identity for one dimension here this is
a LaPlace operator and this is a
gradient operator
and so so for every Jesus that all these
expectations make sense here
now science equation so this is the main
the idea here uh if you have questions
about this maybe Adrian is the best
person to reach out so a science
equation is says that um
uh whenever so whenever Z is not exactly
normal but close to normal you would
expect this quantity to be close to zero
so what we are saying is that for a test
function consider s to be a test
function so that you equate these two
quantities
and find a function f which is a so we
call that of f to be a solution of this
equation
is your little X now a random variable
uh not not at this point
so what are you taking expectation over
them
uh yeah but all the other terms have
expectations as well oh
no at this point I'm no no we don't need
an expectation okay you should remove
the first one and the second expectation
they should be okay not not at this
point we don't have a question so if we
find a solution and
first find a solution and then replace
it by a randomly would take the
expectation
so that's another type for here
X is a constant it's okay to take
expectations there's nothing wrong with
them so
[Laughter]
so uh so with the science method what
you want to do is you want to bound the
absolute value of this term here so that
in return you get the bound on the left
hand side
so but you want to also replace uh
before you start taking expectation and
bound you want to take a w in place of X
for which you want the normal
approximation W is our our candidate for
normal approximation
when we use this time coupling which was
introduced by Chen Roland Louis Chen and
dolin Adrian Roland and also worked we
didn't work with fun function
also on this um so you call a triplet W
so uh just again uh recalling that we
want to our goal is to give
non-approximation for w
now we are finding a triplet triple here
of the uh each of the dimension
such that this falling expression this
condition holds
so if you can for a given W if you can
find a w Prime and G because that this
uh this expression can be satisfied this
equality then you call this a Stein
coupling
again for all Jesus that all the
expectations here make sense
now how does that coupling help you with
the Steins method is if you have a sign
coupling
so and let's say you want this uh
something might be the governance Matrix
and you take D to be the difference
between so the idea here is basically
that you want to expand take the Taylor
approximation of a function at w around
this W Prime which is not too far away
from w
so this is the distance
so this is a difference between the two
vectors then for any P plus 2 times
uh differentiable function h
and that bring the gaussian random
Vector with covenants metric this what
we've shown that
uh this I mean you want to bound this
quantity that so this this is a
complicated expression but uh the idea
here is that all these can be bounded up
this these terms are all dependent upon
the higher order moments of these
differences D and the g term that you
had in the Stein coupling so once you
know the Bound for each of these terms
you can bound this left hand side
quantity okay so these Alphas are just
the vectors such that the total length
is fixed and these are all the
derivatives and substance with well
let's not go into detail so the idea
with this approximation theorem is that
you can bound this quantity by something
that's coming from the Stein coupling
and using this coming from the sign
coupling and also this functions H and
all these Concepts so the main objective
now is if you can bound this quantities
here for your given variables
so
this is what we did and uh find this
over this class of smooth functions so
you need for this one you need P plus 2
times differentiability to uh get this
result and that's why we uh got only
this P plus 2 order here
so just to summarize now the
fluctuations are for the subgroup
densities are explained through this
fluctuations in the sub graph Center
subgraph statistics
and the normal approximation holes uh
even for non-constant graph one and one
more thing I I forgot to point out here
is that the node levels need not be uh
uniform they can come from any
distribution here we don't have to
restrict it to income because you have
already centered them and the correct
metrics which one can compute so it
doesn't have to be a uniform zero one
variable
so this this is our main finding that uh
there's a
the composition and then this is how the
uh the rate that there's a rate of
conversions and Aiden talked about the
statistical applications or
whether a given uh testing a hypothesis
that when you are given a stochastic
block model how do you test like what
statistics you use further
so yeah with the C8 results what
statistics you use
any any other questions
so just to understand the Stein coupling
part the best case which will most
likely never happen is if G is 0
like what what value of G would you most
be most happy with
I don't know
but like for the optimal
we can talk offline yeah yeah sure so we
we give it a choice of G that work that
gives it a Stein coupling and with that
you can compute this moments here
right but maybe if you put the G zero
all of them so ideally you would want G
to be small right no if first time
coupling you also have to make sure that
the uh this relation holds right
uh so you cannot choose G arbitrarily as
well right right
what is a coupling
uh maybe I can explain give you the six
exact uh thing so you when you have you
fix a node you have to remove the
neighborhood effect from here I can give
you the exact question later
I guess the one question is like I mean
how hard is it this to push like all
these Expressions seem to
hold even if you're in the slightly
sparse regime
so what like what breaks down in this
whole you know suppose you you had
I don't know one over square root n
times uh a graph on that's your
connectivity Matrix and you're trying to
understand density of triangle squares
and stuff
which part breaks down do you is there
any good intuition
um
as far as I know nothing breaks down
it's just we were too lazy to do the
actual bounding as you can see from the
Expressions you need to bound
so if you have a if you have in the
dense case you can just up around just
absolute value upper bound but in the
sparse case you actually have to
calculate moments which is much harder
than just having suprema microphone so
it's a matter of how how hard you want
to work to get a result but in the
sparse case it should be we should be
able to do it it's just you have to work
much harder
um yeah so by sparse case you mean when
you uh take this graph on to be some row
N times
don't you soon get the problem that the
number of triangles is less than the
number of edges and then sort of you can
remove all triangles by changing only a
fraction of the edges and then none of
that should work right
so it's sort of if you have sort of high
enough graphs you can't do square root
of and very low
I think what breaks down is just that
variances are going to zero or or a
constant so so that's what's going to
break down yes so there will be an upper
bound it's just maybe in some of the
coordinates the ones with the higher
order graphs as you say that those may
be just uh um how do you say um
yes
I mean how how close you can get without
things breaking down again depends on
how you work on this bound and um how
accurate it is but yeah
right so these bones the the moment
bounds would depend on the Craft only
here if you have a sparse government
this might become even worse
no questions left
[Applause]
so the second in the second half we'll
be having the hike it starts at two we
meet outside the Simon's Institute at
two and start at two so it's gonna be a
random walk
I think Remco has a better idea so if
you want to